companies are more tolerant of losses
than ever before and as long as there's
more growth to achieve companies are
willing to stay at break-even operations
indefinitely a great example of this is
Shopify and Amazon and Uber and Airbnb
and the Zillow and basically every
modern tech company that you can think
of as long as the company is growing
neither the employees or the founders
nor the shareholders care about profit
for all three of these groups having the
company make no money is
counterintuitively the most lucrative
option as no money is being siphoned by
taxes and everything can be reinvested
into further growth